but you're not listening to hecklers in
an arena I got I got hecklers but like
you can't even address it right because
it's so [ __ ] like a right what's the
difference between a Heckler and a
theater and a Heckler Arena are you
still dressing like hey get this [ __ ]
guy out of here I had well I was College
age with college type hecklers and they
would like run up and try to [ __ ]
dive bomb the stage I had a dude next to
me take a shirt I'd be like and in front
of 20 000 people I just hear him he's
like he goes let's trade shirts let's
trade shirt and they scream and I'm like
and then security runs up it pulls up
and he pulls down the stairs the guy's
bouncing on the stairs what I would do I
remember like if somebody in the
nosebleeds heckled me dude I was like I
would do a thing where I would look up
like I could see you and I'd be like hey
dude I'm gonna get to that in a second
all right and I'd make you [ __ ]
believe I do see you I couldn't see [ __ ]
it's like I'm staring into a light but I
would do everything in my power to be
like I gotta Corral and keep these
people like tethered and then when I get
off at the end go oh my God that was
like yeah yeah I mean you can't get
affected by it right no but you have to
let them believe comedy whether no
matter the size of the room is all about
control they need to believe that you're
at the helm in those big shows same
thing that'll get away from you pretty
quick and I'm sure we've seen some of
those shows too it's gnarly
yeah
performing comedy
it's just it's such a [ __ ] vulnerable
art it's like you know like a painting
on the wall is so vulnerable to somebody
just coming up with a marker can of
spray paint you know and it's like
vandalism so vulnerable to [ __ ]
vandalism and that's what a heckling is
people yelling [ __ ] out they're
vandalizing your performance and it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] I saw Carrot Top perform
in Vegas yeah two days it did great
great job yeah great show great guy
great guy he uh had a some he had
somebody Heck on there good wow and he's
he just goes
he goes oh hey I'm not busy I'm not busy
right now
it was so [ __ ] masterful it's
hilarious like I'm not busy right now
come on let's talk about this it's so
great watching the comic in that moment
what unfolds take notes on how to
respond
you just hear the mic drop he's like
everybody hates you
okay all right if you knew how much I
hate you and then he wears a 12-step
program so then he apologizes five
minutes later
you know I love it or he's like yeah I
want this guy out of here and then all
the security guards go over to the guy
he's like no no no no wait wait we can
keep the guy here and now it's just a
[ __ ] tense moment yeah I was gonna
say like where you're at now because
you're how many years in it's I've been
it's been 12 years since you and I did
The Improv that 12 years in and I mean
aside from obviously you're having
incredible success but like I said at
year 15 I still felt like there was a
lot of things I didn't know like where
are you at in terms I know what you're
strong at but like where do you where do
you kind of want to grow out that
experience on stage besides not dealing
with hecklers in the right way uh yeah
it's just that it accumulates over time
it builds up it builds up and then it's
gets to a point where the littlest chirp
and you're like or it's like you tell
people not to record during the show
then it's right when he walks out you
just see a light looking right at the
thing right where where do I want to
grow in my comedy
um
I would say writing you know like I'm
about to uh wrap up the tour I'm on and
and put together my next hour yep how
many dates was it how many dates was the
tour oh this one oh [ __ ] well it was
like a year before like six months
before the pandemic started this tour
before the pandemic oh okay so uh yeah
I've been hitting it hard and it's been
this Evolution with like bits getting
kicked out and everywhere in North
America they've been yeah we've been
everywhere in North America for sure
except Boise Idaho
um and uh
like
I
I'm
I'm really challenging myself with the
next hour I'm gonna put together okay
like like really uh challenging myself
to tell them what you're gonna do
well you don't want to let the cat out
of the bag I'm sure but like oh it's out
it oh it is I mean it's gonna be called
the gone too far tour okay I'm gonna
like like obliterate the lines and go
way too far
um there's need more of that one of the
tent pull bits is gonna be uh actual
breast augmentation surgery
the doctor tells me that I can go double
D
yeah I'll be buying a ticket for that
one
are you gonna do a mean greet topless I
don't know I don't know that I'll be I
think I'm likely to be restored back to
normal before the tour actually
commences you have to sign your own tits
at some point
that's a Rite of Passage
yeah that's everybody I like we're
writing for that one yeah and uh I mean
yeah just writing you know that's uh
that's what what I want to do I want to
like make it masterful right or like
it's like you know I mean I remember
like two sorry
same question to you what do you what do
you want to work I say 2011 was a year
that I when I started I was uh I felt
like I had done so many things in terms
of like what I wanted to do with
physical comedy improvisational comedy
storytelling comedy but where I wanted
to it really accentuate is I wanted to
really learn Stillness on stage I wanted
to be able to have that so 2011 like the
first day of the year or January first
second or third I go I'm Gonna Stand
plant my feet and I'm not gonna move for
a [ __ ] year
and I spent all of 2011 basically for
the most part at the not even taking
like I was like challenging myself
to go I need to be able to tell
everything from right here and trust me
it was different some nights I was like
I just wanted to take it and walk or
prowl the stage or do whatever
but I really hung in there because I
wanted to be able to be cool in the
pocket because I knew if I could get
that and get my breathing okay in that
moment then I could I could bring a
story from like the hundred down to like
zero it even in above it all there's
like two moments
where you know I'm on my front porch we
filmed this at my house in the Hollywood
Hills and I let the entire thing just go
down to like the sound of people
listening and waiting for me
to you know come back with whatever the
next portion of the story is and I
wanted that so bad and after that year I
could finally say that was probably the
hardest thing I I will ever do in
comedies learn Stillness damn I'm a
walker yeah naturally I love it but I
wanted to be able to do that not all the
time but I wanted to be able to know I
could stop and just say you know let me
tell you something this is the truth and
you're not going to interrupt me you're
not going to Heckle me I just want you
to hear me out on something and now I do
that and I do it easily but I couldn't
do that in like 05 to I'd still be like
I'd be like doing this [ __ ] I'm so sorry
it's called Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on Amazon and
type in Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and Order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
Amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on Amazon and buy
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude